the layer one is is the property
settlement layer and we're we're going
to do 350 000 transactions or less a day
100 million transactions a year is the
bandwidth on the layer one
and it would be an ideal layer of one to
move a billion dollars from point a to
point b with the massive security
the role of the layer one is is two
things
one thing is i want to move a large sum
of money
through space
with security i i can move
any amount of bitcoin in a matter of
minutes
for dollars
on layer one
that the second important
feature of the layer one is i need the
money to last forever
right i need the money indestructible
immortal so so the bigger trick is not
to move a billion dollars from here to
tokyo the big trick is to move a billion
dollars from here to the year 2140
and uh and that's
that's what we want to solve with layer
one and and the best real metaphor in
new york city would be the granite or
the schist what you want is a city block
of a bedrock and how long has it been
there like
millions of years it's been there and
how fast you want it to move
you don't
in fact the single thing that's most
important is that it not deflect
if it deflects
a foot in a hundred years it's too much
if it deflects an inch and a hundred
years you might not want that
so the layer one of bitcoin is a
foundation upon which you put weight how
much weight can you put on it
you put a trillion 10 trillion 100
trillion
a quadrillion
how much weight is in it on the bedrock
in in manhattan right think about
hundred story buildings so that the real
key there is the foundational asset
needs to be there at all so the fact
that you can create
a hundred trillion dollar layer one that
would stand for a hundred years that is
the revolutionary breakthrough first
time and the fact that it's ethical
right it's ethical and it's common
property global permissionless extremely
unlikely that would happen
people tried 50 times before and they
all failed they tried 15 000 times after
and they've all been they've all
generally failed 98 have failed and a
couple have like
been less successful but
for the most part
that's
an extraordinary thing now just really
quickly pause just to define some terms
so if you people don't know
layer one is uh that michael's referring
to is
in general what people
know of as the bitcoin technology
originally defined which is the
blockchain there's a consensus mechanism
of proof of work
uh low number of transactions but you
can
[Music]
move a very large amount of money the
reason he's using the term layer one is
now that there's a lot of ideas of layer
two technologies built on top of this
bedrock
that allow you to move a much larger
number of transactions
um
so sort of uh
higher frequency i don't know how what
terminology you want to use but
basically be able to use now something
that is based on bitcoin to then
uh buy stuff be a consumer to transfer
money to use it as currency
just to define some terms
yeah
so
the layer one is the foundation for the
entire cyber economy
and um
we don't want it to move fast what we
want what we want is is immortality
incorrupt immortal and corruptible
indestructible
right that that's what you want
integrity from the layer one now there's
layer two and layer three and layer two
i would define as an open permissionless
non-custodial
protocol
that uses uh the underlying layer one
token as it's as its gas fee so what's
custodial mean and how does the
different markets like uh is lightning
network so lightning network would be an
example of a layer two non-custodial so
the lightning network
will sit on top of uh of layer one it'll
sit on top of bitcoin
and it solves the cl what you want to do
is solve the problem of
it's well and fine i don't want to move
a billion dollars every day what i want
to move is five dollars
a billion times a day
so if i want to move five dollars a
billion times a day i don't really need
to put the entire trillion
dollars of assets at risk every time i
move five dollars
all i really need to do is put a hundred
thousand dollars in a channel or a
million dollars in a channel and then i
do 10 million transactions where i have
a million dollars at risk
and of course it's it's kind of simple
if i if i put
if i lower my security requirement by a
factor of a million
i could probably move the stuff a
million times faster
and that's how lightning works it's
non-custodial because there's no there's
no corporation or custodian or
counterparty you're trusting
right there's a there's the risk of
moving through the channel
but um
lightning is an example of how i go from
350 000 transactions a day to 350
million transactions a day so on that
layer too you could move the bitcoin in
seconds for fractions of pennies
now that's not the end-all be-all
because the truth is there are a lot of
open protocols lightning probably won't
be the only one there could you know
there's an open market competition of
other permissionless open source
protocols to do this work
um and in theory
any any other crypto network that was
deemed to be property deemed to be
non-security you would all you could
also think of as potentially a layer two
to bitcoin
right there's a debate about are there
any and what are they and and we could
leave that for a later time but why do
you think of them
as layer two as opposed to contending
for layer one
yeah actually if they're using their own
token
then they are a layer one if you create
an open protocol that uses the bitcoin
token as the as the fee
then it becomes a layer two okay right
bitcoin itself right incentivizes his
own transactions with its own token and
that's what makes it layer one
okay what's layer three then layer three
is a custodial layer
so if you wanna move bitcoin in
milliseconds for free
you move it through binance or coinbase
or cash app
so this is a very straightforward thing
i mean it seems pretty obvious when you
think about it that they're going to be
hundreds of thousands of layer threes
there may be dozens of layer twos there
might i mean lightning is a1 but it's
not the only one anybody can invent
something
right and and
we can have this debate uh about
custodial non-custodial um
don't you think there's amount of
monopolization possibilities at layer
three
so
um
you know coin you mentioned binance coin
coinbase what if they start to dominate
and basically everybody is using them
practically speaking and then it becomes
too costly to
memorize the uh the private key in your
brain i mean or like a cold storage of
layer one technology the idealists fear
the layer threes because they think and
especially they detest
they would detest a bit
there's almost like a layer 4 by the way
if you want to a layer 4 would be i've
got bitcoin on an application but i
can't withdraw it
so i've got an application that's backed
by bitcoin but the bitcoin is sealed
it's it's a proprietary example and i'll
give you an example of that that would
be like uh
grayscale
if i own a share of gbtc
and and so i own a security actually
you know you could own mstr if you own a
security or you own a product that has
bitcoin embedded in it you get the
benefits of bitcoin but you don't have
the ability to withdraw
the asset you have a security market at
layer four am i understanding this
correctly
i don't know if i would say
i don't not all securities are layer
four but but anything that's a
proprietary product based upon with
bitcoin embedded in it where you can't
withdraw the bitcoin
is another application of bitcoin
so if if you think about different ways
you can use this
you can either stay completely on the
layer one and use the base chain for
your transactions
or you can
limit yourself to layer one and layer
two lightning and the purist would say
we stay there get your bitcoin off the
exchange
but you could also go to the layer three
when cash app uh supported bitcoin they
made it very easy to buy it and then
they gave you the withdrawal
when paypal or i think robin hood let
you buy it they wouldn't let you
withdraw it and it was a big community
uproar and people want
they want these layer threes to to make
it possible to withdraw the bitcoins you
could take it to your own private wallet
and get it off the exchange
i think the answer to the question of
well is is corruption possible is
corruption is possible in all human
institutions and all governments
everywhere the difference between
digital property and physical property
is when you own a building in los
angeles
and the city
politics turn against you you can't move
the building
yeah and when you own a share of a
security
that's like a u.s traded security and
you wish to move to some other country
you can't take the security with you
either
and when you own a bunch of gold and you
try to get through the airport they
might
not let you take it so
bitcoin is advantageous versus all those
because you actually do have the option
to withdraw your asset from the exchange
and if you you know if you had bitcoin
with fidelity and you had shares of
stock with fidelity and if you had uh
bonds and sovereign debt with fidelity
and if you own some
some
you know mutual funds and some other
random limited partnerships with
fidelity none of those things can be
removed from the custodian but the
bitcoin you can
take off uh the exchange you can remove
from the custodian so
so uh
it's still possible there's a deterrent
there's a deterrent that's an
anti-corrupting element
and the phrase is an armed society is a
polite society
because you have the optionality
to withdraw all your assets from the
crypto exchange you can enforce fairness
and at the point where you disagree with
their policies
you can within an hour move your assets
to another counterparty or take personal
custody of those assets
and you don't have that option with most
other forms of property maybe you don't
have as much optionality
with any other form of property on earth
and so what what makes digital property
distinct
is the fact that it has the most
optionality for custody
now coming back to this digital energy
issue the real key point is the energy
moves in milliseconds for free on layer
threes
it moves in seconds or less than seconds
on layer twos it moves in minutes on the
layer one
and
it i don't think it makes any sense to
even think about trying to solve all
three problems on the layer one because
it's impossible to achieve the security
and the incorruptibility and immortality
if you try to build that much speed and
that functionality and performance
in fact
if you come back to the new york model
you really wanted a block of granite a
building and a company
that's what makes the economy
right if you say if i said to you you're
going to build a building but you can
only have one company in it for the life
of the building it would be very fragile
like very brittle what company a hundred
years ago is still relevant today
you want all three layers because they
all oscillate at different frequencies
and
and you know there's a tendency to think
well it's it's got to be this l1 or that
l1 not really and sometimes people think
well i don't really want any l3
but companies
it's not an even war companies are
better
than
crypto asset networks at certain things
if you want complexity you want to
implement complexity or you want to
implement compliance
or customer service right
companies do these things well
right
we know
you couldn't decentralize apple or
netflix or even youtube the performance
wouldn't be there
and the subtlety wouldn't be there and
you can't really legally decentralize
certain forms of banking and insurance
because they become illegal in the
political jurisdiction they're in so
unless you're a crypto anarchist and you
believe in no companies and no nation
states
right
which is just not very practical not
anytime soon once you allow that nation
states will continue and companies have
a role
then the layered architecture follows
and
the free market determines who wins
for example
there are layer threes that uh that's
let you acquire bitcoin and withdraw
bitcoin
there are there are other applications
to let you acquire but not withdraw it
and and they're
they don't get the same market share but
they might give you some other advantage
there are there are certain layer threes
like jack dorsey's cash app where they
just incorporated lightning
and implementation of it so
uh into cash app so that makes it more
that makes it advantageous versus uh
an application that doesn't incorporate
lightning
if you think about
the big picture the big picture is eight
billion people with mobile phones served
by a hundred million companies doing
billions of transactions an hour
and
and the companies are settling with each
other on the base layer in blocks of 80
million at a time
and then the companies are trading with
the consumers
right
in
proprietary layers like layer 3 and then
on occasion people are shuffling assets
across custodians with lightning layer
two because you don't want to pay five
dollars to move fifty dollars you wanna
pay
a twentieth of a penny to move fifty
dollars
and so
all of these things create efficiency in
the economy
and lex if you want to consider how much
efficiency
if if you gave me a billion dollars in
20 years i couldn't find a way to trade
with another company or a counterparty
in nigeria
like
no no amount of money give me 10 billion
dollars i couldn't do it
because you get shut down at the banking
level you can't link up a bank in
nigeria with the bank in the us
you get shut down at this credit card
level because they don't have the credit
card so they won't clear
you get shut down at the at the
compliance fcpa
level because
because uh
you know you wouldn't be able to
implement a system that interfaced with
somebody else's system if it's not in
the right political jurisdiction
on the other hand three entrepreneurs in
nigeria on the weekend could create a
website that would trade in this
lightning economy using open protocols
without asking anybody's permission
so you're talking about something that's
like a million times cheaper
less friction and faster
to do it if you want if you want to get
money to move
you